hablemos un poco acerca del ciclo de la
vida de una célula en particular vamos a
hablar de la interfase de la interfase
t
fase que es parte del ciclo de la vida
de las células y como veremos es la fase
donde la célula pasa la mayor parte de
su vida así que qué te parece si
dibujamos una línea del tiempo de una
célula y digamos que por aquí empiezo
con una célula ésta es una nueva célula
y esta va a entrar a interfase así que
lo voy a dibujar más o menos así voy a
intentar hacer un círculo para que veas
más o menos lo que pasa un ciclo y más o
menos por aquí la célula va a acabar su
interfase todo esto de aquí es la
interfase y en algún punto la célula
estará lista para dividirse entonces
entrarán a la mitosis así que esta
pequeña parte del clima va a ser la
mitosis y la mitosis de una manera más
formal es el proceso por el cual el
núcleo celular se divide en dos núcleos
lo cual es obvio para que después haya
división celular entonces esto de verde
de clint representan la
dosis
y como puedes ver la célula pasa la
mayor parte de su vida en la interfase
donde digamos simplemente existe como
célula en esta etapa vive crece produce
proteínas y realiza otras funciones que
tienen por otra parte la mitosis es una
parte muy corta de su vida es una
fracción muy pequeña pero una muy
interesante y es necesaria para que la
célula se pueda replicar pero como ves
es una fracción muy pequeña ahora bien
en lo que me quiero enfocar en este
vídeo es en la interfase y para hacer
esto vamos a dibujar una célula y para
hacerlo más rápido qué te parece si lo
pego por aquí y lo voy a poner acá
arriba justo así bien pues ya casi está
voy a dibujar por aquí mi membrana
celular ésta de aquí va a ser mi
membrana celular algo más o menos así
dentro de la célula tenemos también todo
este éxito sol no lo olvides está más o
menos así y bueno en este color naranja
tenemos la membrana del núcleo
y dentro del núcleo tenemos el adn y
seguramente estás acostumbrado a ver el
adn de esta manera ver a los cromosomas
completamente enrollados o completamente
condensados como esto también tenemos
otro de color magenta que se vería más o
menos así aquí tendremos a otro de ellos
de nuestros cromosomas pero durante la
interfase los cromosomas no están
enrollados de esta manera entonces no
son fáciles de ver a través del
microscopio simple de luz durante la
mayor parte de la vida de la célula los
cromosomas están completamente
desarrollados como aquí están en su
forma de cromatina y eso lo voy a
apuntar estos de aquí están en su forma
de cruz
china lo que hace que sea muy difícil
que se vean con un micrófono simple no
espera con un microscopio simple y esto
todo esto está desarrollado están las
proteínas y el adn y todo esto está
enmarañado y
también tenemos por aquí otra cosa que
dibuje en que seguramente te preguntarás
oye por qué la dibujé sino dibuje la
mayoría de los organelos y es esto que
tenemos aquí en este se llama centrosoma
y lo dibujé porque será muy importante
así que le voy a poner su nombre este de
aquí será un centro zona centro
tal vez otra cosa que te estés
preguntando sea lo siguiente
tal vez digas hey si no estamos hablando
de las células germinales y si de las
células somáticas éstas deberían de
tener un número diploide de cromosomas
al menos la de los humanos deben de
tener 46 cromosomas no es así parece que
solamente han dibujado dos y eso es
verdad solamente dibuje dos cromosomas
para hacerlo mucho más simple por lo que
asumiremos que esta es una célula de
algún organismo que es muy simple y que
sólo tiene dos cromosomas bueno de
cualquier manera esto de aquí es una
célula nueva y esta va a crecer así que
si esperamos que crezca y tomen
nutrientes del medio ambiente después se
va a ver más o menos de esta manera
vamos a poner una célula que ya creció
la fue a poner más o menos así es una
célula un poco más grande y ahora vamos
a ponerle su núcleo y su centrosoma para
eso vamos a calar lo y lo voy a poner
justo aquí de lujo muy bien y bueno esta
fase en donde la célula sola
está creciendo vamos a ponerle un nombre
a esta fase de aquí le voy a poner el
nombre de g una con un nuevo color le
voy a poner el nombre de g1 por lo tanto
si lo vemos aquí en nuestra línea del
tiempo de la célula que uno se ve más o
menos así es la parte en la que está
creciendo y creciendo y creciendo la
célula más o menos por acá es esta parte
de g1 así que dejamos ponerle nombre g
y bueno distintas células harán esto en
distintos periodos de tiempo pero bueno
como ya te habrás dado cuenta
después la célula tendrá que replicar su
formación y en algún punto tendrá que
replicar todo lo que tiene en el adn y
de hecho esto sucede antes de que pase
la mitosis así que para esto voy a
copiar esta célula que tengo aquí y la
voy a pegar para que sea más rápido todo
esto está la voy a traer y la voy a
pegar justo por acá ya tengo a mi
celular una linda y saludable célula
verde que está creciendo y ahora su adn
se va a replicar entonces en lugar de
tener una copia de su adn
esencialmente ahora tendrá dos copias
pero ojo quiero ser muy cuidadoso con
esto si dibujo este cromosoma de magenta
que tengo aquí y recuerda que está todo
es enrollado así que intentaré hacerle
un poco de justicia a este cromosoma se
va a ver más o menos así y cuando se
replica va a crear una copia de su adn y
se va a ver más o menos así la copia
más o menos así y como podrás ver antes
había un cromosoma con una sola copia de
adn era algo como esto recuerdas y ahora
ojo seguimos teniendo un cromosoma pero
ahora este cromosoma tiene estas dos
copias de adele pero sigue siendo un
solo cromosoma
aunque su material genético fue copiado
a mí déjame ver si lo puedo dibujar una
manera más clara el primero empezamos
con este que tenemos aquí que es un
cromosomas de color magenta lo voy a
dibujar más o menos así lo tengo aquí y
después a este mismo cromosoma a este
mismo cromosoma lo vamos a dibujar pero
ahora con todo su material genético
duplicado y saber más o menos así algo
más o menos así sigue siendo un
cromosoma pero hay dos copias aquí y
como le llamamos estas dos copias bueno
cada una de estas copias se llama
cromática y cuando tenemos a estas dos
de aquí son cromáticas hermanas así que
lo voy a poner aquí estamos hablando
pero más que las prometidas hermanas
estas de aquí son
estas dos son nuestras cromáticas
hermanas ambas pero de cualquier manera
este de aquí con el que empezamos es un
cromosoma pero no
man es muy importante que veas esto este
es un cromosoma uno solo y este de aquí
también es un solo cromosoma es decir
todo esto que tenemos aquí todas estas
dos también siguen siendo un solo
cromosoma después cuando veamos la
mitosis veremos que estas dos cromáticas
hermanas se separan dejan de estar
conectadas y en ese punto nos
referiremos a cada una de ellas como un
cromosoma individual pero ahorita que
todavía están conectadas siguen siendo
un solo cromosoma ahora bien puede ser
que te estés preguntando si hay una
palabra que se refiera a este lugar
justo este lugar donde las dos
cromáticas hermanas están conectadas y
la respuesta es sí a este lugar donde
las dos cromáticas hermanas están
conectadas se le conoce con el nombre de
centro mero ojo
no te vayas a confundir con el
centrosoma este de aquí es el centro
mero centro mero y bien ahora vamos a
fijarnos aquí tengo este cromosoma de
color magenta y ahora se va a replicar
así que lo voy a poner por aquí se va a
replicar sigue siendo un solo cromosoma
a pesar de que tiene el doble del
material genético y tienes estas dos
cromáticas hermanas conectadas con un
centro mero que le voy a poner con este
color y va a estar como por aquí aquí
tengo al centro mero muy bien ahora esto
mismo va a pasar para el cromosoma de
azul así que déjame poner a este
cromosoma de azul también va a replicar
todo su material genético lo tengo por
aquí vamos a tener dos copias de él por
lo que ahora estará formado por dos
cromáticas hermanas que estarán
conectadas también en un centro pero que
lo voy a poner por aquí por aquí tengo
el otro centro mero mientras la
replicación sucede adentro del núcleo el
centrosoma
aquí también se va a duplicar y esto es
parte del ciclo de la vida de una célula
así que lo voy a poner aquí porque ya se
duplicó toda esta parte que estoy
haciendo justo en este momento se le
conoce con el nombre de la fase s donde
toda la información genética se duplica
así que voy a llamar a esta fase a esta
fase con la letra s s y la s es por la
palabra síntesis así que toda esta parte
toda esta parte equivale a la fase s la
voy a poner así aquí tengo la fase s de
la interfase la fase s y antes de entrar
a la mitosis tenemos una parte más que
es esta que voy a poner de este color
esta última parte donde la célula sigue
creciendo se le conoce con el nombre de
g 2
2 así que déjenme representarlo por aquí
voy a copiar esto y lo voy a pegar por
acá este lo voy a pegar por acá date
cuenta que tengo mi membrana del núcleo
celular tengo a mis dos cromosomas ya
replicados cada uno con sus respectivos
centros aquí tengo uno aquí tengo otro y
ya se duplicaron los centrosomas los
centrosomas uno y otro cuidado con la
palabra centrosoma y con la palabra
centro mero y ahora esta célula va a
crecer aún más así que déjame dibujar la
más grande la voy a dibujar a algo así
tengo a mi celular más grande y esta
etapa es lo que se conoce con el nombre
de gestos de g2 así que de aquí para acá
estamos pasando la fase
2 y ahora sin acabando la fase 2 justo
en este punto de que esta célula ahora
está completamente lista para la mitosis